elles demandent une revalorisation de
leur salaire une reconnaissance de leur
statut médical une hausse des effectifs
les sages femmes se mobilisent
aujourd'hui sixième journée d'action
depuis le début de l'année au programme
grèves et manifestations à paris le
cortège est parti du quartier de
montparnasse direction le ministère de
la santé une manifestation qu'a suivi
david khalifa
elles étaient environ assimile à défiler
dans les rues cet après midi de la gare
montparnasse jusqu'ici au ministère de
la santé cemil un chiffre assez
conséquent puisque en france on dénombre
pas moins de 23 mille sage femme un
chiffre qui représente en tout cas la
colère de ces sages femmes lessive est
épuisée elle réclame plusieurs choses
d'abord une revalorisation de leur
salaire à mais est surtout elles ciblent
un manque de reconnaissance de la
profession dans le monde médical dans le
viseur olivier ferrand et sont à ségur
de la santé à cette concertation
imaginer au mois de mars et 2020 avait
totalement mis de côté les sages-femmes
après plusieurs mois de mobilisation
elle avait obtenu gain de cause et une
revalorisation salariale de 183 euros un
net par mois mais cette augmentation de
salaire n'est pas suffisante pour la
plupart des syndicats écoutez nous on a
mille deux cents heures de formation en
plus comparé à des formations de
dentaire ou de pharmacien c'est à dire
que nous en cinq ans on fait
l'équivalent de leur formation en six
ans pour imager c'est comme si vous
aviez une valise que vous partiez en
voyage à la base peut-être en 2009 vous
arriviez à permet cette valise à partir
en voyage depuis les compétences se sont
accumulés mais la formation ne s'est pas
ne s'est pas réformé bah du coup on et
d'équations du coup vous allez rajouter
des vêtements dans votre valise n'arrive
pas à réussir à la ferme et du coup ça a
créé des burn out ça crée des
réorientations sacré du mal-être
étudiants il ya des réponses qui sont
apportées mais qui sont pas encore
suffisantes qui nous permettent pas de
prendre en charge correctement les
patientes qui ne donne pas
d'attractivité à notre profession et
c'est ça finalement aujourd'hui qu'on
déplore cette augmentation de 183 euros
ok certes mais je veux dire c'est pas ça
qui va permettre d'attirer à nos futurs
collègues quand elles ont fait cinq
années d'études après le bac quelles
sont la responsabilité entre autres de
la vie mais des enfants et de la santé
des femmes et de leurs familles par la
suite et qu'elles terminent leurs études
en pouvant espérer gagner 2000 euros
bruts par mois s'est pas satisfaisant on
déplore un manque de considération mais
aussi un manque criant d'effectifs
plusieurs politiques ont fait le
déplacement pour soutenir cette
mobilisation deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 et yannick
jadot député vert et anne hidalgo maire
de paris la candidate ps pour l'élection
présidentielle 2022 et yannick jadot a
insisté sur le fait qu' il fallait
augmenter le salaire d'un secteur public
pour anne hidalgo la maire de paris elle
a préféré pointer du doigt est la crise
sanitaire qui a mis en avant une fois de
plus tous les problèmes tous les maux de
la santé publique la crise sanitaire sur
laquelle tous les soignants ont fait
tenir le système de santé parce qu'ils
se sont arrachés la peau parce qu'ils
ont pris sur eux ils ont pris sur leur
énergie ils ont pris sur leurs
compétences sur le fait que ce sont des
métiers de passion ce qu'ils font et ça
a tenu et là on arrive à la sortie de
cette crise sanitaire et on nous dit
mais c'est bon ça a été revalorisé banon
est-ce que sa part de tellement loin et
le système c'est tellement d'éviter que
c'est pas du tout suffisant et que ceux
que posent les sages femmes c'est
vraiment l'accueil au monde des tout
petits il ya eu ce travail c'est par
boris cyrulnik qui est un travail
exceptionnel sur les 1000 jours et on
dit c'est exceptionnel et tout le monde
hier mais c'est exceptionnel et bien
traduit son cela en ac nous voulons
évidemment
réhaussé revaloriser fortement les
salaires notamment les salaires d'entrée
dans les professions on voit bien que je
veux dire aujourd'hui une sage-femme qui
commence à 1600 avec des horaires
impossibles avec une charge
psychologique ils chargent de de
responsabilité sur la qualité de
l'accouchement du suivi des femmes il
faut absolument revaloriser ces salaires
repenser les formations recond c'est les
conditions de travail ce n'est pas
qu'une enjeux de salaires c'est aussi
parfois sur certains territoires un
enjeu majeur d'effectifs des sages
femmes venues de toute la france de peau
de toulouse ii de cherbourg ou bien
encore de marseille l'objectif est de
mettre la pression sur olivier ferrand
et de se faire entendre cette sixième
journée de mobilisation ne compte pas
s'arrêter là puisque les sages femmes
tant qu'ils n'auront pas obtenu gain de
cause continuerons à manifester leur
colère dans les rues et à à lancer des
préavis est de grève comme ça a été le
cas le 24 septembre dernier